bienvenue à tous pareils ça kztv vous
emmène aujourd'hui à l'institut
d'optique c'est l'une des grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs de l'université paris
saclay et c'est ici que s'est déroulée
la première conférence tedx saclay un
projet lancé par une force et m notre
équipe était sur place
le laser apollon une porte bien son nom
celui du dieu grec de la lumière
ce sera le laser le plus puissant au
monde il se construit ici sur notre
territoire dans les sous sols du cea le
commissariat à l'énergie atomique
nous allons tout dévoiler notre rubrique
décryptage
on s'intéresse aujourd'hui à la
technologie bing
c'est une petite révolution pour la
conception des bâtiments mais deux sites
des réseaux et enfin avant de revenir
sur tous les événements à venir dans les
semaines qui viennent dans notre agenda
nous allons vous faire revivre le
festival 50,1
c'était la première édition de ce
festival de documentaires qui s'est
déroulé à saint quentin en yvelines
coop 21 oblige le thème retenu cette
année c'était l'environnement c'était
donc la première conférence tedx sa clé
elle a eu lieu juste derrière moi dans
les locaux de l'institut d'optique l'une
des grandes écoles d'ingénieurs de
l'université paris saclay et c'est une
or cn qui s'est lancé dans cette
aventure
son nom assia van gysel elle a réuni
autour d'elle tous les acteurs du
plateau sur un thème fort les lumières
notre équipe était présent à cette
conférence inédite
jeudi 12 novembre
le soir j'ai eu plaisir d'animer en fait
le premier tlx à clé qui a eu lieu à
l'institut d'optique sur sur paris
saclay c'était un événement qui a eu un
vif succès peut-être c'est un organisme
américain qui a lancé l'idée dans les
années 80 c'est une série de conférences
soit s'ils ont une demi-journée ou une
journée ou plusieurs jours où on fait
appel à des intervenants
c'est généralement multidisciplinaire
c'est les intervenants en des
interventions à faire entre 10 minutes
et 18 minutes maximum qu'ils sont filmés
en vidéo qui sont relayés et ses
interventions elle touche des
disciplines aussi variées que la science
l'art le design la technologie
l'entrepreneuriat et ce sont des sujets
généralement qui ont un enjeu de société
énorme face au succès des conférences
ted
aux etats unis ils ont décidé de lancer
des licences au niveau mondial c'est
pour ça qu'il est le petit x avec un nom
de ville
les critères c'est d'avoir plusieurs
disciplines on a commencé par un artiste
après il ya eu un physicien après il ya
eu quelqu'un qui a parlé d'une ovation
frugal en fait les thèmes sont vraiment
très différent des parcours différents
je vois tedx comme un pont entre
plusieurs disciplines contre paris
saclay et le reste du monde et entre
tous les acteurs qui veulent construire
des choses mais vous de paris saclay je
suis une passionnée de développement
personnel et je suis convaincu qu'en
fait cette connaissance de soi même pour
quelqu'un qui veut entreprendre est
vraiment clé apprenez à vous connaître
pour vous ouvrir à plus d'opportunités
plus de synchronicité et ouvrir créer
des ponts avec mes autres sur par
exemple on s'est dit que ce n'est pas
juste un spectacle où l'on vient pour se
distraire tedx c'est quelque chose qui
les inspirent pour pousser la personne
qui le regarde à aller chercher dans ses
rêves les plus profonds et à se mettre
en action et à y aller qui si j'arrive à
l'amener à tous les habitants paris
saclay j'aurais gagné mon pari
il porte bien son nom celui du dieu grec
de la lumière le laser apollon sera le
plus puissant au monde
il se construit sur ce site sur le
plateau de saclay dans les sous sols du
cea le commissariat à l'énergie atomique
ce projet emblématique de l'université
paris saclay réuni 12 laboratoires de
pointe
nous avons rencontré le directeur du
projet françois minard off mais aussi
pascal mono chercheurs du cea saclay
on se trouve à 7 mètres sous terre dans
les locaux qui accueillait un
accélérateur de particules qui a été
construit à la fin des années 60 qui
était désaffecté et qui constitue un
terrain d'accueil extraordinaire pour le
laser apollon pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que la dalle le procès
d'une stabilité absolument incroyable
fait deux mètres d'épaisseur et donc
elle permet aux faisceaux laser de se
propager sur des centaines de mètres
tout en conservant une précision de
pointe est de l'ordre du micron dans les
salles expérimentales
l'autre aspect c'est que l offre une
radioprotection extrêmement lourde des
murs de quatre mètre quatre-vingt
d'épaisseur absolument partout sur
l'installation ce qui était vraiment
intéressant pour nous puisque ce laser
va servir en quelque sorte d'
accélérateur de particules miniature on
se trouve ici dans une salle
expérimental qui va accueillir le laser
apollon est ici le faisceau laser qui
fait typiquement 40 cm de diamètre va
être concentré jusqu'à des dimensions
qui sont équivalentes à taille d'un
cheveu voire inférieurs pour atteindre d
éclairement absolument extraordinaires
qui sont plus d'un million de milliards
de fois supérieure à celui qui règne à
la surface du soleil
dans ces conditions on étudie ici on va
étudier comment la matière réagi lorsque
allait illuminer de façon aussi intense
apollon pour moi est à la fois un projet
phare de l'université paris saclay mais
aussi un symbole de l'université paris
saclay parce qu'il réunit dès le départ
onze laboratoires du plateau de saclay
avec un ensemble de tutelle assez large
et qui est soutenu par un grand nombre
de financement à la fois locaux et
nationaux et européens l'objectif étant
à la fois de de construire une nouvelle
installation à l' usage d'une large
communauté est aussi de développer des
thèmes de recherche vraiment à la pointe
des connaissances actuelles
depuis le printemps le laser est en
cours de construction dans les salles
dédié au laser sa construction va se
poursuivre dans l'année qui vient et les
premiers tirs lasers sont attendus pour
2010 cette date à laquelle une
installation commencera à accueillir des
chercheurs du monde entier et mime gros
plan sur cette technologie qui
révolutionnent la façon dont les
bâtiments les infrastructures et les
réseaux techniques sont planifiés qu'ont
su créer et gérer
bîmes cela signifie modélisation des
données des bâtiments mais comment ça
marche c'est notre rubrique décryptage
le même se sont pressées passé simple
déjà ce processus en aucune façon faire
les choses bon la version officielle
anglaise de l'information en ligne
c'est à la base d'un principe pour
concevoir et construire des bâtiments
qui encore une fois mon humble avis se
fonde sur deux éléments principaux le
premier temps la collaboration et aussi
sur l'information unix alors que chaque
élément d'un bâtiment représente une
série d'informations qui rattaché à
différents corps de métiers bon exemple
plus banal étant probablement mur qui
bat qui forcément placé par larchitecte
qui peut avoir des fonctions structurale
qui contient des éléments acoustique par
exemple donc le même élément du bâtiment
requis à l'import d'information de
différent de différentes parties
ce qui fait que c'est un processus très
collaboratif ce qu'on avait pas prêt
avant d'avoir pu tout le monde qui
décide et dans son coin qui faisait leur
plein et puis on l'essayé d'amalgamé
tout sur la fin
hélas elle assure un peu le contraire
donc dès le départ on essaie d'intégrer
tout le monde on travaille dans une
maquette numérique
donc ça il faut faire la différence
entre le processus qui le bim et la
maquette numérique qui est qu'il produit
qu'on va créer donc à partir de certains
outils donc les informations acoustiques
sont dans la maquette numérique qui
ensuite lui traduit d'importer en
fonction des technologies pour récupérer
l'information dont toujours cette
information uniqlo et enfin l'analyse
le nsc une école mais c'est aussi
quelque part un mini usine ce qu'on
retrouve des machines de haute précision
pour les laboratoires de chercheurs donc
le bim a permis de rentrer ces
informations là c'est à dire qu'on a
modélisé un physiquement on a on a
repris les dimensions des machines on va
recréer et on les a positionnés dans la
maquette en trois dimensions dans le
site du projet cette facilité de
compréhension permet d'aller plus loin
du coup dans le niveau de conception
jiwok caractérisé le bim
pour moi c'est un outil de communication
un outil communication très important
parce qu'on est capable de comprendre et
de voir les choses sur de façon
immédiate
on s'est pas mal trop mal débrouillé
puisque on a reçu le prix de dübendorf
2015 grâce à ce problème s'il doit
caractériser le projet jeunesse c'est
surtout une aventure collective
notamment grâce au boom
du cinéma à présent avec la première
édition du festival 50 1 1 en forme de
clin d'oeil ce festival international du
documentaire s'est déroulée à saint
quentin en yvelines
coop 21 oblige le thème retenu était à
l'environnement alors pourquoi se lancer
dans une telle aventure et pour quel
résultat
on écoute tout de suite les deux
organisateurs
origine de ce festival c'est thierry qui
un jour ont déjà les est ensemble m'a
dit est ce que tu es prêt pour faire un
festival
moi je dis bien sûr ok
faisons quelque chose donc on est parti
c'est au mois de mars d'une feuille
blanche et c'est comme ça qu'on a
commencé à monter ce festival qui à son
apogée ce soir avec la cérémonie
d'ouverture
notez les fils soixante dix huit pour
produisait de plus en plus de
documentaires des programmes longs des
femmes de réflexion et je trouvais que
la meilleure façon de valoriser ses
documentaires c'était de créer un
festival dans le cinéma c'est bien il
peut avoir un moment d'échangé avec le
public s'est passé avec la télévision
d'où l'idée de proposer des
documentaires bien sûr des films et bien
sûr qu'ils ne sont pas de téléphiles
autour d'un festival avec un v remise de
prix et surtout en intégrant non
seulement des salles de cinéma mais
également d'autres partenariats
la médiathèque ubs culot escudé
librairie voilà donc faire vraiment un
événement vivant sur l'ensemble du
territoire
c'est vrai qu'on était parti comme c'est
thierry sur faire un festival du film
documentaire
cette année c'était normal de se
raccrocher à l'environnement de la fin
de l'année et notamment à tout ce qui se
passait en france avec la coop 21 donc
très naturellement on a orienté sophie
ce premier festival du film documentaire
sur des documentaires liés à
l'environnement
c'est une première édition qui s'est
fait quasiment sans budget et sans
permanent donc visé c'était de voir
l'appétence à la fois du public y avait
également la d équipement des salles de
spectacles des salles de cinéma pour
voir ça répondait à une attente la
cérémonie d'ouverture c'est 470
personnes la salle est pleine on va voir
sur l'ensemble des autres événements il
ya 50 événements saint quentin c'est 50
moment pour un festival
donc on fera un bilan après on verra
s'ils ont reconduit le
le festival voilà essayer de plus de
films documentaires encore sur le goût
votre site
on aimerait faire des choses notamment
avec le cnc au niveau du site de brodard
les archives du film entre latins de
partenariat qui se met 30 là je l'espère
si le festival demain sur 7
il
une manifestation organisée dans le
cadre de la coop 21 le pps participent à
cette grande conférence sur le climat et
présentera le réseau de chaleur et de
froid
nous vous en avions parlé lors d'un
précédent reportage souvenez vous autre
date à retenir le 10 décembre c'est la
nouvelle édition de paris saclay invest
hc événement consacré aux startups
innovantes et justement quand on parle
de start up innovantes
oui up organise le mardi 15 décembre la
soirée de lancement d'auto-stop 2.0
saclay son application smartphone oui up
veut mettre en relation piétons et
automobilistes sur le territoire venez
vous laisser convaincre autour d'un
cocktail sdat partir de 18h au proto 204
voilà pour cet agenda qui est bien
chargé j'espère que vous avez tous notés
mais sinon pas d'inquiétude vous
retrouverez toutes ses dates sur notre
site eps.fr vous pourrez aussi suivre
l'information
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite
m